un estadio indoor cámaras en cada
esquina y streamers como presidentes de
los equipos Bienvenidos a la kingsley
una nueva era del deporte
Juan es entrenador esta mezcla de
videojuego y fútbol le permite utilizar
una tarjeta especial en cualquier
momento pero solo una vez por partido
cuando quieran activar la carta de
presidente vale antes de activarla y
luego ya pulsas el pulsador
esta arma secreta le permite al
entrenador activar un penal o hacer que
un gol valga el doble o el triple
este fútbol 7 fue concebido
especialmente para internet y consta de
dos medios tiempos de 20 minutos
porque no hay público no hay tanta
presión pero pero bueno al final cada
decisión es muy determinante porque hay
mucha gente viéndonos por detrás Adri es
el presidente de uno de los dos equipos
del torneo a sus 26 años este
influenciador suma tres millones y medio
de seguidores en tiktok
al anterior partido del barrio que ya la
subida a mi canal de YouTube siempre
subo las reacciones analizando mi
partido Al haber tantos elementos tantas
cartas tanto tanta cosa no le da tiempo
a pestañear Por así decirlo entonces
tiene que estar muy atento porque todo
el rato está pasando cosas y la duración
Yo creo que es clave las audiencias de
Lake molestan a algunos como a Javier
tebas el presidente de la liga española
que comparó este juego a un circo para
este periodista bien Podría agitar la
marea uno de los mayores impactos el
entretenimiento de los últimos cinco
años o el mayor relacionado con el
deporte eso no me cabe duda el fútbol en
general debería plantearse si no hay que
renovar algunas cosas la final de la
Kings League se disputará el 26 de Marzo
en el mítico